guys here come here bud Jacob I love you
I have a sad face I'll see you
there's a bunch of beluga whales out in
England
all right guys we're here in Homer
Alaska and uh me and my brother and my
nephew here we're gonna be doing some
serious fishing
foreign
Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and we're going fishing for two
days so yeah this whole video is kind of
a spur of the moment thing we just got
finished doing the longest road trip in
the United States driving from Key West
Florida to Dead Horse Alaska we finished
up that video drove back to Anchorage
we're ready to fly out and the whole
family tested positive for covid well I
mean I got covered and then I gave it to
the whole family and now I'm out of
quarantine and they're not so we are
going fishing so my kids are exiled from
the public school system for a good two
and a half weeks and uh my poor wife is
stuck inside with them and uh I'm going
fishing
and uh we're gonna go cook up a whole
bunch of awesome fish if we can't catch
something we just don't know what we're
doing we don't know what we're doing
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're pulling out of the Homer Harbor
and this is the most stressful part of
the whole process reminds me of the high
school parking lot paranoid I'm gonna
hit something
this is the worst spot yeah he said
[Music]
well my brother here is actually here on
a work trip so we're gonna drop him off
back at the dock around lunch time so
we're not gonna venture out too far this
morning plus we have no idea what we're
doing so no point in running out far
when you don't know where you're going
okay we're on a steep shelf it goes from
about 100 feet down to 400 feet and we
got a little Ridge that we're gonna
drift over the top of it so that's
that's what I'm going to try we're gonna
see what happens we're gonna throw a
bunch of dead fish down here and see if
something eats it
okay
put a little trolling Herring head on
top on the end of a sushi spoon we're
gonna drop this down
you get tired
no it's a little flounder so what is it
a little baby
there we go
oh look at all the sea lice on him he is
loaded
[Music]
I mean halibut fishing is the same as
catfishing basically just bigger and
deeper so we got these high low rings I
mean I've got a million catfish on these
things
and this is just a bigger halibut
version I got a three pound lead and
I've got these two droppers kind of like
a high low rig I'm gonna put big old
Herring on these so we're gonna have the
smaller rods with the jigging action
going on at the back of the boat and
then one of these Big Boys is right
underneath the boat
oh
there he goes what you got oh you got a
little kelp grilling
yeah a little kelp Greely
oh no little sculpin there you go little
little sculping our third species
there we go well this is a nice little
spot we kind of get our confidence
boosted up but we want some real halibut
not these little dinky ones so we're
gonna keep moving around see if we can't
find something better
I'm just cruising around looking for a
rock pile or just anything that is
interesting oh see look at that there's
something going on right there
literally the big old sea otter right
there just chilling that's a good sign
and these guys are still going waiting
for the bottom so we're at 228 feet we
got a bigger jig head this is a serious
fish here
what you do is you put your thumb you
like Bam Bam all right uh you got it you
got a little we got a nice little drift
here but not a lot is going on so we're
gonna pull up try another spot you know
maybe 10 feet and so all right got
another spot with some marks down there
we're gonna see if there's any fish
not huge but it feels like something
little baby halibut
foreign
got some chew marks on there Dan he just
missed the hook
[Music]
what do you got what do you got
oh a little folic yeah
great little efficiency chips there nice
catch dad
a snag sculpin
uh
good
oh
that is a flounder because he's got that
rough skin right it's a nice flounder a
little kelp grilling
well he caught a few things here and
there but it's time for Dan to go to his
meeting so we're gonna drop him back at
the harbor and me and Ransom are gonna
go try to find some big halibut
all right Dan enjoy working
all right let's go catch a hundred pound
halibut but now that we've got the dead
weight gone we're gonna go uh out a
little bit further and see if we can't
catch some more serious sized halibut
we're gonna go to the mouth of the bay
here we go sea otter those sea otters
aren't little they're like six feet long
or more
you can see right here we got a trough
where it gets deep down here so this is
deeper this is shallower I'm just going
to kind of scoot all around here and see
if we can't find something all right
birthday boy you ready to try this out
yeah all right let's just see what's
happening we we have no clue what we're
doing
wanna use this one I do
oh there we go another tiny guy
I mean we're catching little dinkers
like nobody's business we just need to
get the bigger boys just hit something
big
that's more of what we're looking for
oh look at that color buddy
oh my that's huge oh look at that
look at that oh that's a skate Oh I
thought we had a halibut on
take it out there's a skate but this is
a baby one they get six feet wide here
in Alaska this is just a little tiny guy
I hear you can eat them but you know
I'm I just don't know what I would do
with it
we caught something big that one's nice
oh
I think this might be the smallest one
today
Francis might be even smaller
a lot of little dinks and one skate but
that's not what we're looking for let's
go try another spot see what we can find
a couple big old sea otters just sitting
right there it's one two three
all right I'm gonna switch to try a
different lore here we're gonna see if
that works oh Branson's got something
serious yeah this doesn't look like a
little flounder
it's kind of weak
yeah Ron's bending yep oh I can see big
color
and get him closer
oh that's that's it it's a little
chicken out of it but it's a eater let's
John keep him oh
that was a little one but we were really
excited to have it
well we saw our best halibut on this
Drift But I'm gonna keep going I think
we can find an even better spot
all right let's try another spot
how tiny that is oh that's the record
for the smallest right there
we gotta try another spot oh jellyfish
a whale just come out of the water a
humpback whale right there
hey little
little baby hell of it that might be one
of the smallest halibut ever but there
we go that was a hell of it
[Music]
well we didn't exactly Slaughter the
fish today but we caught a ton of those
little flounders hopefully tomorrow
we'll get on the Halibut um but we're
just gonna go and clean up the boat and
get it all all organized and ready for
tonight and uh tomorrow we're gonna give
it another go well good morning it's
another beautiful day here in the hover
small boat harbor this time we're gonna
do it I think we learned some valuable
lessons yesterday
okay all right to cast this off Dan so
yesterday we watched a lot of boats
leave the harbor and none of them were
fishing anywhere near us so that tells
me that probably we need to go a little
further out because that's what everyone
else is doing so we got a bit more fuel
today we're gonna go out to the mouth of
the bay to a place called the compass
rose because on all of the maps
where they put the compass rose is a
good fishing spot so if you get a map of
catamac bay that where they put the
north south thing that's where you want
to go big area though I mean it's it's
not like it's a little spot it's many
square miles we gotta figure out where
to fish in the compass rose but that
seems to be where a lot of people are
going and that's where we're gonna go to
all right guys we're in the compass rose
let's cruise around a little bit until
we see something good on the fish finder
we don't know what we're doing so we're
gonna drop here and see what happens
after a day on the boat what
shirt of little flounder here kind of
like yesterday we're in a pile of
flounder ransom's got another one over
there yo look at that little guy you
catch these little guys and you spend so
much time messing with them that you
don't you don't get a chance to catch a
big one they're all
so that's that's actually a baby halibut
he's got smooth skin and a little bit
more elongated
there you go they're spunkier too
that's a flounder though right she looks
like it yeah wait no it's a flounder oh
yeah I guess it's good oh look at that
yeah it's a little baby halibut that's
something oh
damn we got a real fish
Escape
oh crap you lost the rod oh son of a gun
I'm just gonna pop him off right here
okay okay yeah that's a good sized one
yeah
oh
that's huge yeah
all of a sudden Ransom goes hey I got
something I got him snagged on the rod
look like he pulls it out of the ocean
I think that's the Catch of the Day yeah
that was The Catch of the Day that's the
MVP play there Ransom we got the rod
back
oh there you go little halibut oh that's
that's a decent fish right there awesome
oh that's a hell of it oh did he pop off
oh he popped off that was a definitely a
hell of it you feel him though you can
feel it probably like that pumping oh
there we go just got hooked up again
that's a flounder that's a flounder but
that's a different
there's a towel hooked that's why it was
nice flounder it's a rough skin I mean
it's really rough and you see how he's
kind of round instead of triangular but
look at that it's a beautiful fish
all right Dad what you got what you got
I never saw it
what do you got dad
yeah maybe that's
it's it's edible I think we might want
to seriously consider that one it's
almost noon there's a lot of meat on
halibut so I mean that's a that's a meal
I think I just broke the record for the
smallest whatever I can see through this
one was he trying to eat my lure or mate
with it or become buddies or flounder
yeah it's a respectable size flounder oh
there we go
there's something proper on that I think
it's a flounder I can see the stripes on
the fins there we go there's another big
flounder but
that's a flounder nice something
flounder
there's a little elephant
you're a flounder Slayer okay
let's cut some yeah it feels like a hell
of it that feels like a real holiday
I'll have to how to get the Gap I'm
working on it
oh
There's an actual keeper hell of it
yep
hiding for a little halibut well yeah
what a beautiful beautiful halibut
they're so meaty this is my first
halibut I've ever caught up on a Do-it
myself Charter
you got something here
but how big I mean oh yeah I mean I
think we're at this point in the game we
should keep that yep let's do it
oh dad's got one I think we found our
chicken halibut Farm
yeah it is a good size nice flounder oh
Dan just got tagged
there we go
I mean these are really fun on that
light tackle aren't they yeah these
These are such tiny halibut I mean if
you go in a charter you'll yeah I mean
these are like the smallest ones you'll
see all day nice little halibut that'll
be awesome man we really are catching
these halibut on light tackle this is a
little Akuma Azores I mean this is a
really great jigging rod for Rockfish
and you know Cod and that sort of thing
but it is is definitely on the light
side for halibut you got a good one
Ransom
[Music]
this is the most awkward technique I've
ever seen okay Luke it's really heavy
this is the heaviest one I've lifted up
yet
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh oh crap it's a huge Outlet
yes you did
your pants that's what he's saying
holy crap
Ransom High Five man big fish of the day
check it out I got those ripped jeans
that the kids think are so cool nowadays
of it oh
that one got all tangled up and all
sorts of stuff
oh well that's it
six halibut some of them are
embarrassingly small but we were
desperate okay
there are some very small halibut in
that cooler that's all right we got them
and they're gonna taste fabulous yeah
tomorrow it tastes better so these are
gonna taste really really good oh I'm
actually the best fisherman here
headed out to go fishing for Rockfish
and something wrong with the engine
can't get it to rev up all the way and
so we can only do about 10 miles per
hour so we're gonna we're gonna just
kind of head back
well the engine we kept croaking out
when I'd put it in neutral and had all
problems but we made it back to Shore
and we're alive and we didn't break
anything all right let's pull them out
look at that it's so tight
there's I think that's by slightly less
tiny one
bye
the difference between isn't mine
that's that's it oh look it's a baby and
it's Mommy can you put your put your
other hand in there little Logan yeah
there's big and little one two three you
hold it up any higher Ransom
well guys you want to see what halibut's
been eating here's the stomach
craps look at all these crabs he was
eating
just full of them
good job that was actually big so this
is what was in the stomach of this
halibut little a little baby halibut
you see there's the eyes
[Music]
get a lot of meat off a halibut yeah
that's
that's a lot of meat oh you got a little
little tapeworm huh yeah right there
yeah yeah that's all right just cook it
fully there's more meat
okay
[Music]
we got the boat clean and the key
returned we got to drive four hours back
to Anchorage and uh we're gonna cook up
some halibut I'm in the mood for some
fish tacos that sound good yeah well
guys we're back here at Anchorage and
I've got about four hours of sleep under
my belt but we're gonna make halibut
tacos so buckle up it's gonna be tasty
yeah
[Music]
fire alarm
[Applause]
s
foreign
girl
avocado pico de gallo that was amazing
Luke I really hope I can taste this
oh that's good now unfortunately Becca
and Melanie are both recovering from
covid so their sense of smell and taste
just a little uh off but maybe that's a
good thing with my cooking did I put too
many necks you like it I'm still trying
to decide if I can taste anything hey
Jacob do you like it yeah
you like it Melody oh yeah you taste it
I can actually taste it yeah
that's good
well guys that was some delicious
halibut and I hope you guys enjoyed this
little trip it was kind of uh unplanned
sort of thing where uh we just kind of
got stuck here in Anchorage for a week
and decided we're gonna go halibut
fishing but we had such a great time
catching those halibut on light gear uh
and we hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you'd like to see more travel videos
to Alaska more fishing videos I'll put
links down in the video description to
other similar videos but thanks for
watching we guys hope you enjoy this and
uh don't forget to click subscribe we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]